so much to talk about first of all you
were Swedish and there's a misconception
what the hell
and so we just it's like the United
Nations here we get
but you know there's this uh belief that
everyone who's Swedish is blonde blue
eyes they and there's a belief that
that's everybody clearly you're proof
that that's not the case well then
Exmark can I have a ball cup yeah this
is oh okay oh really and you dyed your
eyes for tonight yeah I did yeah
is your is your family uh is anyone the
sort of stereotype in your family I
always get that question but what
parents really from right do you know
where your dad's from
the second question exactly that's nice
yeah yeah no they're both from very
small villages like uh from up north and
south of Sweden and um yeah I'm well I'm
a court of finish but that doesn't
really make me much darker I love the
fins I'm a huge God in Finland
we'll talk about that another time
please it's true I'm like what
Hasselhoff is to Germany I am to Finland
[Applause]
he's not still a lifeguard he's he's
graduated to something else yeah he's
having a Swedish like talk show he is I
haven't seen it but we've got a this is
the first time hearing about that I've
got to see that show I've got to be on
that show I will be on that show that's
my promise
you're thinking I don't care whatever uh
you know so many Americans it's not our
greatest trait but we're not always as
curious as we should be about other
countries and if you ask most Americans
about Sweden they would probably say
okay I know about Swedish Fish and Ikea
that's it the funny thing was that I
learned about Swedish Fish I was um I
hadn't been to the States but I went to
Canada when I was 13. um
[Applause]
yeah
they love geography yeah the main places
they go nuts so then when I yeah I and I
also I'm sorry I was in the store and I
was like what's this it's Swedish
Festival yeah from your country and I
had never ever so they don't have them
you don't have it we're being lied to
here
we think it's this exotic candy from
your country and they they're lying to
us it's not true it's not true I can't
we do have you have Ikea yes and I guess
I've had the same experience as
many other people in other countries I I
remember I bought my I I was 15 I was
very young when I moved away from my
home to go and do ballet in Stockholm I
had no money so I went to Ikea to at
least have a table and two chairs and I
spent hours putting the things together
yeah and then I sat there on the floor
because of course it was the last school
missing yeah I just burst into tears I
put them in the corner to kind of fix
them but they stood there for a year
yeah they always there's some guy at the
Ikea Factory who takes one screw away
just before it goes out the door
but I I mean I do love to go that the
fact that you can't get out that you
kind of need to go into the entrance and
go through the whole thing yes in
Stockholm they've actually go up on the
fifth floor and you have to Circle all
the way down to get out and I always buy
so much you just buy stuff I don't know
they know what they're doing I just go
there for the meatballs and then I can
never get out
I'll make them for you you'll make them
for me sometimes
you would make me homemade meatballs yes
that was not gonna happen uh